más de 60 años después de su primera
aparición astérix sigue siendo el
personaje de cómic favorito de los
franceses y su popularidad no se ha
visto mermada por el fallecimiento de
sus emblemáticos creadores cocina y
uderzo algo que no se le ha escapado a
la prensa que acudió en masa a la
presentación del volumen 39 de la serie
astérix y el grifo el nivel era tan alto
durante los años dorados de astérix que
es casi imposible hacerlo mejor sabemos
que estamos haciendo las cosas de forma
diferente con nuestra propia voz no
somos goscinny y uderzo este es el
quinto volumen publicado por los nuevos
autores de ideas con hat y jennifer y
desde que se hicieron cargo de la serie
en 2013 su anterior título de ley de
viajes han sido hicks vendió más de 15
millones de ejemplares sólo en francia
convirtiéndose en el libro más vendido
del país en 2019 y el éxito no es sólo
en francia con cientos de millones de
lectores en todo el mundo y obras
traducidas a más de 110 idiomas la marca
steaks representa una verdadera mina de
oro para sus editores
cada año vendemos de un millón de
ejemplares en francia hemos crecido más
de un 25 por ciento en los últimos dos
años para hacer un personaje de 60 años
son sigue funcionando bastante bien con
cuatro películas de acción real 10
adaptaciones cinematográficas de
animación y un parque temático se espera
que la franquicia de esther y obélix
siga siendo un modelo de éxito en los
próximos años